what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be breaking down the death of every
single hashira in the demon slayer
series this includes tragic deaths in
battle like what happened to our boy
rengoku but because the demon slayer
manga gives us a glimpse into the
distant future i will also cover those
hashira who just died of old age or met
their end in some other non-combat
fashion this means that if you are anime
only you still have time to turn away
but if you choose to continue this video
will contain demon player manga spoilers
so proceed with caution you have been
warned and of course if you like our
demon slayer content and you want to see
more in the future just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps a lot and if you want a
totally free way to support the channel
in a very meaningful way just click that
subscribe button on youtube that makes
all the difference okay first up let's
talk about the hashida who died during
the mugen train arc and whose death was
already covered in the anime and the
mugen train movie after tanjiro and
inosuke managed to defeat animu upper
moon 3 akasa makes his appearance and he
tries to kill tanjiro since tanjiro is
already injured at this point the flame
hashira kyojuro rengoku steps up to
protect him from akaza akaza is
immediately impressed with rangoku's
swordsmanship skills and he invites
rengoku to become a demon like him now
of course rengaku would never even
consider that as an option this man has
dedicated his entire life to fighting
demons and he would rather die than
become one of them for his part akaza
can't understand why anyone would want
to remain a weak human who is doomed to
lead a short life instead of becoming an
overpowered demon who can live forever
rengoku responds that death is the very
thing that makes human life so precious
and beautiful in rengoku's own words
growing old and dying is what gives
meaning and beauty to the fleeting span
of a human life it's precisely because
we age and die that our lives have value
and nobility akaza still doesn't get it
and he thinks that it would be a shame
for a talented warrior like rengoku to
die so soon but rengoku doesn't think
that death is a bad thing death is only
natural for human beings and so whenever
death may come it is not to be feared
that is because death is a perfectly
natural part of life at this point
tanjiro attempts to help rangoku in the
fight against akazab but rengoku tells
tanjiro to stay back if his wounds
reopen now he will probably die so he
has to sit this one out after a brutal
and epic struggle akaza manages to deal
a fatal blow to rengoku by sticking his
entire arm through rengoku's stomach
akaza then tries to convince rangoku one
more time to become a demon i mean after
all if he doesn't become a demon now he
will definitely die from this wound and
yet instead of entertaining akasa's
proposal rengoku decides to keep
fighting against akaza despite that
severe injury that is tearing through
him in fact rengoku actually uses his
own wound to his advantage the sun is
about to rise and rengoku's plan is to
keep akaza right where he is by keeping
his arm trapped inside his own stomach
then once the sun rises and makes
contact with akaza the demon will burn
up and die rengaku's wound will
definitely kill him but he intends to
take akaza down with him now up to this
point akaza was just impressed and
intrigued by rengoku but now akasa
begins to actually fear for his own life
he tries his best to break free from
rengaku's grip but the hashira refuses
to budge akaza becomes desperate and he
cuts his own arms off in order to escape
from rengoku's grip as rengoku drops
down to his knees akaza runs away into
the forest before the rising sun can
catch up to him a heartbroken tanjiro
throws his sword at the fleeing akaza
and screams at him to stop running away
like a coward tanjiro says that rengoku
is braver and more honorable than akaza
will ever be because he fought to save
the lives of others until the very end
and he didn't just run away like a
dishonorable coward tanjiro proclaims
that rengoku won this fight because even
though akasa is alive and rangoku is
dying akasa is running away while
rengoku stood his ground and fought with
honor until the very end and i have to
say that tanjiro is 100
right akaza is an upper demon moon and
so he is objectively stronger than
rengoku but even though rengoku was
fatally injured he nearly killed akaza
by forcing him to face the sunlight and
in the end akaza had to turn his back
and run away from his opponent in terms
of this battle in particular akaza lost
and rengoku won as he is dying rengoku
does not show fear or sadness he stays
true to his convictions until the very
end and he even takes the time to tell
tangero to visit the rangaku family home
so he can learn more about the hinokami
kagura he also asks tanjiro to tell his
younger brother to follow his own path
and to tell his father to take care of
himself so even as he is dying rengoku
is thinking about helping tanjiro and
he's thinking about his father and his
brother and yeah this is the same father
who mistreated him and discouraged him
for practically his entire life that is
just the type of person that rengoku is
he is always doing his best to help
others and he doesn't hold any sort of
grudge against anyone including his
father rengoku was a true hero a true
chad and a true bro and even though we
lost him way way too soon his death was
so powerful honorable and meaningful
next up we have the equally noble and
tragic death of the insect hashira
shinobu kocho shinobu's death happens
inside the infinity castle as she
confronts upper moon to doma in chapter
141 we get a flashback to the death of
shinobu's older sister kanai as she is
dying kanae tells shinobu to leave the
demon's air core so she can live out a
normal and happy life and actually get
to grow old but shinobu refuses to quit
and she vows to avenge her sister by
killing the very demon who killed her
that demon is none other than upper moon
2 doma who managed to fatally injure
kanye before running away due to the
fact that the sun was about to come out
so in that sense the fight between doma
and kanai was similar to the fight
between akaza and rengoku in the present
shinobu walks in on dolma devouring a
bunch of different women in his day job
dolma is the founder of a cult called
eternal paradise and he uses the cult to
attract followers that he later devours
dolma has the warped belief that because
everyone fears death they can just live
forever through him after he devours
them and because his victims are no
longer afraid of anything or suffering
in any way after he eats them doma
believes that he actually saved them
this is truly one of the most warped and
sadistic philosophies that i have ever
come across and dolma is definitely one
of the most devious and evil villains in
the history of anime and manga now
shinobu knows that this is the demon who
killed her sister based on the
description of him that kane gave her
before passing away for his part doma
recalls his battle with kanae after
seeing shinobu's haori coat he remembers
that kanai was kind and cute and he
regrets that he couldn't finish
devouring her because the sun came up
and he had to flee damn bro read the
room anyway an infuriated chinobu then
lunges at dolma and pierces his face
with her sword and so the epic battle to
avenge kanai begins initially doma
believes that shinobu is just too weak
to pose a threat to him because she's
physically incapable of severing his
head since a demon can't be killed by
just jabbing and stabbing them shinobu's
efforts will prove to be useless in the
end because doma will just keep
regenerating but shinobu has one
important ace up her sleeve she has
laced her sword with potent wisteria
poison which is used to immobilize and
defeat demons however despite stabbing
doma multiple times using the poison
laced weapon the demon seems relatively
unharmed his power as the second
strongest demon moon allows him to
rapidly develop a resistance to a wide
variety of poisonous concoctions so this
means that doma has many natural
advantages over shinobu including raw
physical strength the ability to
regenerate increased poison resistance
and so on but for her part shinobu
possesses amazing speed and this speed
allows her to get around doma's defenses
and land hit after hit on him and yet
even though she is able to hurt doma
with her attacks shinobu just doesn't
seem capable of causing enough damage to
actually defeat him she is simply too
short and physically weak to lop off the
head of an upper demon moon and unless
she can find a way to do that it's game
over ultimately dolma manages to
seriously injure shinobu to the point
that she can barely breathe she's lost a
lot of blood one of her lungs is
punctured and it looks like her attempt
to avenge her sister will end in failure
but then in that very moment shinobu
sees a vision of her sister kanai
despite the fact that kanai had
previously told her sister to just quit
being a demon slayer and live a normal
life this time kanai tells shinobu to
stand up she tells her that now that
she's already here and now that she's
decided to defeat this demon then she
must defeat him shinobu forces herself
to stand up despite having multiple
serious injuries and she attacks dolma
using that incredible speed she is so
fast that even an overpowered upper
demon moon like doma cannot anticipate
her next move she goes in down low and
manages to pierce doma right through the
neck with her poison laced sword even
though she isn't strong enough to
decapitate doma with a single thrust
shinobu hopes that poisoning him in such
a vital spot will be enough to kill him
as all of this is happening shinobu
thinks back to the time when tanjiro
asked her whether she was angry back
then tanjiro could tell that something
was off about her otherwise calm
demeanor he could tell that she was
hiding a lot of anger inside of her she
now admits that yes she's always been
angry her parents were killed her older
sister was killed and all of her
apprentices except for kanawha were also
killed by demons and by the way i know
this might be confusing because their
names are so similar but remember that
chinobo's older sister is kanae with an
e at the end and her apprentice is kanao
with an o at the end the demons killed
so many innocent people they destroyed
so many families and this is why shinobu
has been absolutely furious for a very
long time unfortunately for shinobu doma
still appears to be unaffected by her
poison poison just doesn't seem to work
on him and it's as if all of her
incredible efforts have been in vain and
being the absolute psycho that he is
doma grabs shinobu as if he's hugging
her as tears flow down his face he tells
shinobu how admirable it is that she
keeps fighting so bravely despite the
fact that she doesn't stand a chance she
is so weak and yet she's trying so hard
and doma thinks that this is absolutely
adorable doma says that because
shinobu's determination has impressed
him so much he now considers her worthy
of being eaten by him so that the two of
them can be together forever when doma
asks shinobu if she has any last words
like the true badass that she is shinobu
just tells him to go to hell wow what an
evil monster doma is and what an
absolute chad last shinobu has proven
herself to be then as a helpless kanao
watches in shock and despair doma begins
absorbing shinabu into his own demon
body kano tries to attack doma and save
shinobu using the fourth form of flower
breathing but doma is too fast he smiles
and begins to gloat about how fine
feasts seem to be coming to him one
after the other a furious kano calls out
doma for what he is right to his face
he is a blatant sociopath who is
completely incapable of feeling normal
human emotions he pretends to show
emotions because he has learned over
time what the socially appropriate
response seems to be in any given
situation but deep inside he actually
feels nothing he is nothing but an empty
shell that is why in the end kanai had
actually felt sorry for him before she
died doma isn't too happy about what
kanawha said and so the two of them
engage in fierce combat despite doing a
commendable job in the fight and despite
having incredible speed and special eye
powers kanao simply cannot defeat a
demon of doma's caliber just as doma
manages to take her sword and just as it
looks like it's finally game over for
kano our boy inosuke shows up and joins
the fight against doma a brief but epic
battle ensues between kanaweninosuke on
the one side and doma on the other a
battle during which we learned the
backstory of inosuka's mother and how he
ended up in the wilderness and then
shinobu herself returns to center stage
for her incredible final act it turns
out that chinobu knew ahead of time that
in order to defeat upper moon to doma
the man who killed her sister she would
have to sacrifice her own life and so
she always intended to do exactly that
she knew that doma was a glutton who
loved devouring women in particular and
she knew that he wouldn't be able to
resist devouring a female hashira with a
strong body so shinobu did the
unthinkable she began ingesting wisteria
flower poison little by little for over
a year so that she would slowly build a
resistance to it and so that she could
have a lot of it circulating through her
body when doma eventually consumed her
with her sword alone shinobu was only
able to deliver a small amount of the
poison into doma's body but if he
consumed her he will consume 70 times
the lethal amount of wisteria flower
poison the author of demon slayer later
stated in the extra pages to volume 19
of the manga that she actually intended
for the number to be 700 times the
lethal amount but she mistakenly wrote
70. and so as doma is fighting kano and
inosuke all that poison finally kicks in
his body begins breaking down his very
bones begin to melt and even with his
demonic regeneration he cannot undo the
effects of such an immense amount of
poison dolma desperately tries to keep
fighting but kano and inosuke work
together to cut off his head and so
upper moon 2 doma is finally destroyed
as he is dying doma meets shinobu once
again presumably somewhere between this
life and the next shinobu gets to see
the outcome of her sacrifice and doma
must accept his death at her hands
but while you might expect doma to be
angry or scared or shocked this absolute
lunatic tells shinobu that he finally
understands what love is because he now
knows that he loves
her
doma then asks shinobu if she would
accompany him to hell and shinobu smiles
and says after you you worthless bastard
wow
i have so much respect for shinobu's
amazing sacrifice and how she prepared
for over a year knowing full well that
she would die just so she could save the
world from one of the most powerful and
most evil demons who knows how things
would have turned out in the end if doma
had survived the battle against shinobu
and if he had been able to help muzon in
the final showdown against the demon
slayers without shinobu's sacrifice the
demons could easily have won in the end
and countless innocent lives could have
been lost in the future and while it's
no secret that i absolutely love shinobu
as a character and i have so much
respect for her epic sacrifice i have to
say that doma remained a terrifying and
fascinating villain until the very end
his final words to shinobu were so
creepy and so unexpected and overall he
was just such a well-constructed and
memorable villain this was an amazing
fight and shinobu's death was both truly
heroic and truly meaningful now let's
talk about the death of muichiro tokito
the mist hashira muichiro dies during
the intense battle against upper demon
moon 1 kokushibo inside the infinity
castle a fight that also includes genya
sanemi and gyome but the first person to
come face to face with kokushibo is
muichiro himself and as soon as he sees
the upper demon moon 1 muichiro can tell
that he is different from all the other
demon moons kokushibo has a profound and
majestic presence and he is also a
master swordsman which leads muiro to
conclude that kokushibo was once a demon
slayer upper moon one's aura is so
intimidating that muichiro begins to
shake and his whole body seems to be
refusing to fight which is something
that has never happened to him before
and while muichiro is attempting to get
a grip on himself kokushibo calmly asks
for his name muichiro identifies himself
and kokushibo responds that his own
human name was michikatsu tsugikuni
although the tsugikuni name must have
died out over time kokushibo can tell
that muichiro is a descendant of his own
child in other words kokushibo is the
direct ancestor of muichiro muichiro is
obviously surprised to hear this but
nonetheless he summons up the courage
and strength to calm his nerves and
prepare for battle and he manages to do
this so quickly that kokushibo praises
his spiritual strength muichiro then
commences his attack on kokushibo using
missed breathing but he's unable to land
a hit even so kokushibo is definitely
impressed by muichiro's strength and
courage especially since he can tell
that muichiro is only 14 years old oh
yeah in case you needed a reminder
muichiro the missed hashira is only 14
years old at this point in the story
kokushibo also notices that the demon
slayer mark has now appeared on
muichiro's face and as muchero continues
to use impressive techniques in his
attempt to hit kokushibo the upper moon
one decides that it would be poor
etiquette if he didn't draw his own
sword and so kokushiba reveals his
breathing style
moon breathing the very first swing of
kokushibo's moon breathing slices off
muichiro's left hand and muichiro is
stunned to learn that kokushibo can use
a breathing technique even after
becoming a demon muichiro quickly makes
a tourniquet from his shirt and just
keeps on fighting practically unfazed by
such a sudden loss of his hand what a
little chad this guy is he may only be
14 but he is 100 worthy of being called
a hashira in fact kokushibo is so moved
by the resilience of his descendant that
he decides that killing him would be a
shame instead kokushiba plans to ask
muzon to turn muichiro into a demon
that's about the time that genya shows
up and he attempts to sneak up on
kokushibo and shoot him from behind but
kokushiba has already spotted genya and
using his insane speed he manages to
essentially slice genya into pieces but
to kokushiba's surprise genya is still
alive and before he can finish genya off
he is also attacked by the wind hashira
sanemi sanemi vows to make kokushibo pay
for slicing up his little brother and
after kokushiba draws his sword we
witness a fierce battle between wind
breathing and moon breathing after a
while the stone hashirak gyome also
joins the fight and the stage is set for
the final showdown against upper demon
moon 1.
according to kokushibo gyome is an
example of someone who has perfected
their physical form to the utmost and he
hasn't seen such an incredible human
warrior in 300 years this will become
important as the battle goes on because
gyome as the strongest living hashira is
a crucial factor in the eventual outcome
of this epic clash and the epic clash
against muzon and while the fight
between moon breathing and stone
breathing rages the absolute mad lad
muichiro who up to this point had been
pinned down after being pierced by his
own sword pulls the sword out of his own
chest with his bare hands what a super
human feet that is this 14 year old kid
pushed through so much pain and anguish
in order to free himself muichiro knows
that he will likely die from blood loss
as a result of the injuries that he has
already sustained but he is determined
to do something useful before he dies so
he does his best to wrap his wounds and
stop the bleeding and then he helps
genjia put his mangled body back
together although both of them are
severely injured they vow to keep
fighting until the very end genya then
consumes some of kokushiba's hair and as
genya and muichiro are trying to pick
themselves up from the ground and rejoin
the fight gyome and sunemi are already
tag-teaming kokushibo in a desperate
attempt to take his head off and defeat
him muichiro finally rejoins the fray
when he steps in to save sanemi from one
of kokushiba's attacks and then
determined to help while he is still
able to move muichiro attacks kokushibo
while kokushibo is distracted by gyome
and sanemi muichiro manages to move
close enough to pierce kokushibo's torso
with his sword muishiro loses one of his
legs in the process but he doesn't even
care he has accepted death and all he
wants to do is be as useful as possible
in this fight before he dies it is hard
to even describe just how selfless brave
and valiant this 14 year old kid is and
he deserves all the respect in the world
muichiro decides that he must protect
yomma and tsunami at all costs so that
they can survive and then be able to
continue the fight against the muzon he
is so determined to help defeat
kokushiba before he dies that his
nichiren blade suddenly turns red and
this newly evolved blade causes such
pain to kokushibo that he is unable to
move on top of that a dying genya uses
his blood demon art to manifest a tree
around kokushibo helping to keep him
immobile long enough for sunim and
gyomei to decapitate him at first it
looks like kokushiba's power is so great
that even decapitation cannot defeat him
to everyone's utter shock he is able to
regenerate even his head but this second
head looks nothing like a human head it
is a monstrous demonic head and when
kokushibo catches a glimpse of his own
face he is disgusted he cannot believe
that he allowed his fear of defeat to
take away his humanity and turn him into
such a monster and as kokushibo is
having this massive crisis of conscience
his body begins to break apart in the
very place that muichiro had stabbed him
he is then finished off by gyome and
sanomi and thus upper demon moon one
kokushiba falls in defeat genya and
muichiro both die from the wounds that
they sustained during this grueling
battle and as muichiro's life leaves his
body gyome thanks him from the bottom of
his heart because it is thanks to
muichiro that they were able to defeat
upper moon one kokushibo in the first
place kyomei says that for someone so
young muichiro was magnificent to the
very end and he vows to defeat muzon
before telling muichiro that he can now
rest in peace
as he leaves this life for the next
muichiro meets his twin brother yuichiro
once again a crying yuichiro asks his
brother why he chose to die fighting at
such a young age when he could have just
run away and lived a long life but
muichiro says that he could never
abandon his comrades he was happy when
he was with his friends and comrades he
had good times with them and thanks to
them he was able to smile again after
the family tragedy that he had lived
through crying the two brothers embrace
each other and that is how muichiro's
life ends well this life anyway in the
end muichiro didn't live up to the
expectations of his ancestor kokushibo
because he refused to become a demon
like him but he definitely did live up
to the legacy of his other ancestor
kokushibo's twin brother and the
original breath of the sun user yorichi
tsugikuni muichiro proved himself to be
a phenomenal warrior a worthy hashira
and a selfless comrade despite being
only 14 years old without him kokushiba
would not have been defeated and without
kokushiba's defeat there would be simply
no way for the demon slayers to deal
with both him and muzon at the same time
the battle against muzon would almost
certainly have ended in failure if not
for the legendary sacrifice of muichiro
tokito and i mean of course i respect
genya's sacrifice as well but this video
is specifically about the hashida okay
so while the previous three hashira that
we covered died in three different
battles against three different
opponents the next three hashira that we
will be covering all die during the same
battle against muzan because of that i
will have to cover all three of them at
the same time and i'm of course talking
about obanai iguro mitsuri khanroji and
gyome himejima yes you heard that right
best girl and top waifu of the series
mitsuri is one of them and no i'm still
not over it this battle really gets
going once the infinity castle is
destroyed and muzon finds himself
outside in the open and facing giu
tanjiro mitsuri and igoro there is still
an hour and a half until sunrise at this
point but if the demon slayers can keep
muzon busy until then the sunlight will
eventually kill him since muzon would
survive even if the demon slayers took
his head the sun is the only surefire
method of defeating him muzon is not
only much stronger than all the other
demons but he also mixes his blood into
his attacks and this blood serves as a
deadly poison that destroys the cells of
anyone who comes into contact with them
early on in the fight in chapter 184
tanjiro is affected by this poison his
entire face is disfigured and he
collapses to the ground and for a while
it appears that he has died so yeah
right from the get-go it is established
that muzon is unbelievably powerful and
that no one is safe in this fight not
even the most important characters with
tanjiro down for the count the hashida
are struggling against muzon and they
are suffering multiple lacerations as
they try to keep up with the king of the
demons just as mitsuri is about to be
killed by one of muzon's weird tentacle
tube things gyome shows up and saves her
muzan recognizes him as the hashira who
defeated kokushibo and right after that
sanemy attacks muzon and slices him from
behind before setting him on fire so we
now have five different hashira all in
the same place and all fighting muzon oh
and the strongest demon slayer of all
murata is also there you might think
that he would just finish muzan off on
his own but instead he is told to grab
tanjiro's unconscious body and drag him
off to safety as the battle against
muzon rages at first the demon king
seems to be getting even stronger and
faster as the battle continues and the
hashira are finding it impossible to
keep up iguru sees that mitsuri is not
doing well so in an attempt to protect
her he hands her off to the lower ranked
demon slayers and tells them to take
care of her while he returns to the
battlefield mitsuri cries that she wants
to go with him but igoro is determined
to protect her he wishes that the two of
them had met under more normal
circumstances and it's clear that igoro
has strong feelings for mitsuri however
igor feels that he isn't worthy of
mitsuri because his bloodline is corrupt
and impure for centuries his family only
seemed to give birth to girls and iguru
appeared to have been the only boy who
was born into the family in 370 years
upon his birth he was confined to a
prison cell where he was fond over by
his mother sisters and aunts and brought
rich foods to eat every single day iguru
eventually learns that his entire family
worshipped a female demon who had the
body of a snake and that they had been
feeding their own offspring to this
demon as sacrifices in return the demon
made the family rich by giving them the
valuables of all the other humans that
she killed because igura was born with
unusual eyes the snake demon took a
liking to him and decided that she
couldn't eat him as a baby instead she
would wait until he was older and fatten
him up first she also had his mouth
sliced so that it would more closely
resemble her own snake mouth and that is
why igoro always wears that mask on his
face
thankfully before he was eaten igor
managed to escape his cell the snake
demon tried to capture him but she was
killed by the flame hashira shinjuro
but before she was killed the snake
demon killed nearly everyone in igoro's
large family because they failed to
prevent his escape and so iguro
continued to carry the burden of his
family's sins as well as the death of
his family members for his entire life
he had decided long ago that he wanted
to die defeating muzon in order to
purify the filthy blood of his family
but if he were to one day be reborn as a
human in a peaceful world without demons
he would finally confess his true
feelings for mitsuri back on the
battlefield iguro has already rejoined
the others in the fight against muzon
and he is trying his best to buy as much
time as possible before the sun comes
out but there is still over an hour
until sunrise an hour and 14 minutes to
be precise igoro believes himself to be
weak because he was raised in a cage
where the heaviest thing that he would
ever lift was like a pair of chopsticks
he also feels that he has contributed
less to this fight than anyone else and
so just like muichiro in the fight
against kokushibo he is determined to
make some sort of impact on the outcome
before he dies igor already received
intel about how moichiro managed to turn
his blade red before he died and he
desperately wants to do the same he
ultimately succeeds but he ends up
spending way too much of his energy in
the process and once his sword finally
becomes red he can barely move due to a
lack of oxygen muzon is about to cut him
down red blade or no red blade but that
is when yet more demon slayers join the
fight inosuke zenitsu and kano appear
and they too begin relentlessly
attacking muzon while saving igor's life
in the process the demon slayers realize
that wounds made by a red blade take
longer for muzon to heal and so they all
start turning their own blades red it's
like a red blade bargain sail with one
hour and three minutes until sunrise the
demon slayers now have more fighters on
the battlefield and they also have red
blades on their side so things are
finally looking a little bit better for
the good guys by looking into the
transparent world gyoume realizes that
muzon has seven hearts and five brains
spread out throughout his body and that
is why he can't be killed even if his
head is lopped off so gyome tells the
others to peer into the transparent
world in order to see muzon's vital
organs if the other demon slayers are
able to see the exact locations of all
of muzon's brains and hearts maybe they
will be able to execute a coordinated
attack and take them all out at the same
time this seems like a pretty reasonable
plan but unfortunately for the demon
slayers in a shocking turn of events
that mostly happens off-screen they're
all quickly laid out by muzon the only
one still conscious is kanao who is on
her knees and pointing a broken blade at
the advancing muzon muzon prepares to
eliminate kanawha once and for all but
he is suddenly struck with hinokami
kagura beneficent radiance and his left
arm is cut off by a resurgent tanjiro
tanjiro was successfully healed at least
partially thanks to yushiro's medical
ninja skills that said tanjiro's face is
still deformed from the demon poison and
musa even says that it's hard to tell
which one of them is the demon now back
when he was unconscious tanjiro saw a
vision of yorichi and this vision helped
him come up with a strategy to defeat
muzon but even though tundra is nowhere
near as strong as yurichi was muzon
still can't seem to kill him which makes
muzan realize that his own body is
slowing down for some reason searching
through tamayo's memories muzon learns
that she used a drug on him that sped up
his aging to a massive extent he is now
aging 50 years for every 60 seconds this
means that his demonic body is diverting
a lot of energy to counteract the
effects of aging and that is what is
slowing him down elsewhere on the
battlefield yoshido is trying to help
gyome but he is so badly injured that it
may be impossible for him to keep
fighting with the strongest hashida
seemingly out of battle and with over 50
minutes to go until sunrise things don't
look good for tanjiro who at the moment
is fighting muzan alone thankfully iguro
comes to tangido's rescue thanks to his
previous engagement with muzon iguro now
has massive lacerations across his face
making him unable to see he is relying
on his snake kaburamaru to show him the
way igoro bravely engages in battle
against muzan despite having been
blinded and igor's actions at this point
literally save tanjiro's life then
suddenly thanks to tameo's aging potion
and muzan's weakening regeneration
tanjiro is able to see the scars that
yoricci left on moves on hundreds of
years ago tanjiro realizes that these
scars are muzon's weak spots and through
these cars yorichi is showing them the
way to defeat the demon king from beyond
the grave realizing that his weaknesses
have been exposed muzon actually tries
to run away from the fight but iguru
manages to stop him by jumping on top of
him from behind and piercing his neck
with his blade this is a critical moment
in the battle and iguro deserves all the
credit if igoro hadn't intervened and if
muzon had managed to run away he likely
would have gone into hiding until he
found a way to completely heal his body
and if that had happened then the demon
slayers would have been at square one
and all of their sacrifices would have
been for nothing tanjiro gives igoro
yushiro's magic seal things which allow
him to share the sight of his snake
kaburamaru as if the snake's eyes were
his own meanwhile muzon is in disbelief
about the fact that these demon slayers
are so determined and so relentless and
he begins to legitimately worry for his
life as his body continues to get weaker
and slower now with only 35 minutes left
until sunrise muzon decides to cut his
losses and divide his body into a
thousand pieces in order to escape the
same way he had managed to escape from
yurichi all those years ago
but when he attempts to divide his body
muzon realizes that he can't do it
tamayo's potion also included something
that is preventing muzon from dividing
and on top of that when his body gets
weak enough tamayo's drug will begin to
destroy his cells
in this moment after over a thousand
years of life muza knows that he is
actually dying but muzon isn't ready to
give up yet he creates an explosion that
once again turns the battlefield on its
head and yet bit by bit he continues to
get weaker far from giving up the demon
slayers keep getting back up and
fighting him inosuke and zenitsu are
fighting again and even gyome and giu
manage to get back to their feet muzon
suffers attack after attack from tanjiro
inosuke and zenitsu and then an injured
mitsuri returns igor returns everyone is
fighting desperately because every
second matters and the sun is about to
come up as dawn finally breaks muzon
turns into a giant baby-like creature in
one final desperate attempt to escape
the sun but sanemy and gyome managed to
keep him from escaping and then as big
baby muzon tries to burrow underground
all the hashida joined together in an
epic team attack and in the end big baby
muzon is finally destroyed by the
sunlight and yet despite this amazing
historic victory over a demon that has
haunted the world for over a thousand
years the demon slayers have also paid a
very steep price for the victory when
the medics attempt to help gyome he
tells them not to waste any medication
or supplies on him because he is already
done for this is his final request to
the demonstrator core as he passes away
from his injuries and as he reunites in
the afterlife with the orphans that he
had cared for before he became a demon
slayer these are the orphans that gyome
had raised in a temple before a demon
attack killed most of them gyome had
always thought that three of the
children disobeyed his command to hide
behind him because they thought that he
was weak and blind and so he couldn't
possibly protect them he thought that
they just didn't trust him enough and so
they tried to run away on their own but
these children now apologize for
disobeying his instructions and they
revealed that they ran because they
wanted to help one wanted to find a
weapon another wanted to call for help
and so on they weren't trying to run
away from gyome because they didn't
think he could help them they loved
gyome and they wanted to help him
because he was facing down a demon on
his own despite being blind gyome
apologizes that he couldn't protect them
but the children tell him not to
apologize they all hug him and tell him
that they love him and then gyome and
his orphans proceed into the afterlife
together at the same time that this is
happening iguru is holding a dai mitsuri
in his arms mitsuri can feel that she is
dying and igurus says that he is dying
as well thankfully igoro is able to
assure mitsuri that their sacrifice was
worthwhile muzon has finally been
defeated the two of them recall the
first time that they met and they
reminisce about all the good times they
had together despite the fact that they
were both considered abnormal by society
they made each other feel like they were
both normal and there was nothing wrong
with them the two of them made each
other so happy and mitsuri asks igoro if
they are reborn as humans again in the
next life could she please be his bride
igoro says yes and he vows that this
time he will make her happy and he will
protect her so she doesn't die young and
so both of them pass away together
holding each other in their arms
wow this was really such a touching
moment i was going to make a joke along
the lines of screw you igor mitsuri is
my waifu but i can't even do it because
it was such a deep emotional moment it's
kind of joke proof and this is how gyome
iguro and mitsuri die in the battle
against muzad when you look back at this
fight in particular there were so many
times when the hashira willingly
sacrificed their bodies just so they
could make even the smallest
contribution to defeating muzon or just
so they could buy even a little bit of
time before sunrise they embraced death
willingly even though they had no
guarantee that their sacrifice would
actually lead to defeating the demon
king if things had been even slightly
different muzon could easily have won
the fight and all their sacrifices would
have been for nothing but they fought so
bravely they did their best to
contribute to this massive team effort
to defeat muzon and in the end their
tragic sacrifices made all the
difference in the world and with that we
just covered the six hashira who died in
battle during the course of the series
in terms of former hashira jigoro
kuwaijima the former thunder hashira
also died tragically when he committed
seppuku in order to atone for the sins
of his student kaigaku a student who
willingly chose to become a demon the
other current and former hashira
including giu sanomi shinjuro sakonji
and tengen all die of old age sometime
after the main story comes to an end
some fans have speculated that giu and
tsunami will die at age 25 because they
manage to awaken their demon slayer
marks but it is possible to live a long
life with a demon's layer mark for
example yorichi was born with it and yet
he lived well into his 80s on top of
that it is possible that the death of
muzon has changed things and eliminated
the so-called curse of the demon slayer
mark at the very least we know that both
giu and sanemy lived long enough to
start families and have descendants i
really hope that you guys enjoyed this
video i know it was long because i
really wanted to do justice to the
sacrifices of the six hashira who gave
their lives in battle but at the same
time there is so much about their lives
and them as characters that i still had
to omit if you'd like me to do a deeper
dive into any one of them or into any
specific battle in the series definitely
let me know down in the comments below
it's a totally free way to directly
support the channel and with long videos
like this one when i see a lot of people
liking and subscribing it really makes
me feel like the effort was worthwhile
thank you in advance you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys